[Müzik]
Evet değerli dostlar Hepiniz hoş
geldiniz
Öncelikle deprem felaketinde hayatlarını
kaybetmiş olan
vatandaşlarımıza rahmet diliyorum
kederli ailelerine de başsağlığı
diliyorum Evet ben Çiğdem Karaca
27 yıldır İngilizce öğretmenliği
yapmaktayım çarşamba günü emekli
oluyorum arkadaşlar Evet yeni genç nesle
artık bırakmamız lazım 27 yıldır
üniversitede çalıştığım dönemdeki
öğrencilerime Milli Eğitimin her
kademesindeki öğrencilerine ve dernekte
dezavantajlı çocuklarla birlikte
çalışmaktayız onların hepsine bana
kattıkları tecrübelerden dolayı teşekkür
ederim Evet Çarşamba günü emekli
dilekçesini veriyorum dedim ve ne kadar
güzel bir şey ki Peki efendim
Lisesi ve ben de ilk konuşmacısı oldum
herhalde buji bile olsa gerek bu kadar
güzel bir video bile bana nasip oldu tüm
Emeği geçen herkese çok teşekkür
ediyorum
Evet yaşadığımız Topraklar bundan 3000
yıl önce
Likya uygarlığının toprakları Evet Likya
demek Işıklar Ülkesi demek
Likya kadını demek ışık saçan demek
bizle Işık saçmalıydık bugüne
kadılıklarla hareketlerle çalıştım ama
eksik bir halka vardı
Bu din Evet bu da kadınlar ya kadınlar
kadınlar için kim ne yapmıştı Evet hep
bir şeyler yapılmıştı ama geçmişte
kalmıştı yok olmuştu sürdürülebilirliği
yok çünkü Evet kadınların sosyal yaşamı
katılması
güçlendirilmesi ekonomik olarak
bağımsızlaştırılması ürettiğinin
pazarının sağlanması ve Kendi Ayakları
üzerinde durarak bunların satışını
yapması gerekiyordu Evet çünkü eğitimci
olarak şunu
akıllı kadın eşittir akıllı çocuk O
yüzden Anneleri eğitmek zorundaydık
anneler para kazanmalıydı sosyal hayatta
yerine almalıydı Evet benim eşim bir
siyasetçi bu bunun bize kazandırdığı en
iyi yön Yaşadığımız çevrenin sosyal
ekonomik ve kültürel yapısını en ince
detayına kadar hakim olduk ve biz ne
yapabiliriz daha iyi düşündük her
şeyimiz var Fethiye olarak A'dan Z'ye el
sanatları tarantulizm gıda aklımıza
gelebilecek her şeyimiz var Ama
sürdürülebilirliğimiz yok markalaşma yok
satış alanları yok böyle ekle ne oluyor
Hiç bir yerde her şeyimiz var ama hiçbir
şeyimiz yok oluyor arkadaşlar Evet bu
yüzden ne yapmalıydık
sorduğumuzda sürdürülebilirliğini
sağlamak için sordurduğu sorduğumuzda
kadınlarımıza niçin üretmiyorsun daha
çok üret daha çok öğret dedikleri bana
şu olmuştu 15 yıl boyunca para etmiyorum
kuzum alan yok satan yok çamuru Evet bu
benim için bir bölüm noktasıydı bu cümle
ile Ben düşündüm düşündüm bugün nasıl
saptırırım nasıl para ettiririm bir
yandan seçip çalışması bir yandan Yarın
kazanırsak bunu nasıl telafi edeceğiz
düşüncesindeydi bunun için ne
yapabilirdik yakın tarihimize baktık
bizim bir liderimiz var Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk her durumda başka bir yerde
Cevap aramaya gerek yok o bu durumda ne
yapardı Evet o köy enstitüleri kurmuştu
Köy Enstitüleri aydınlık geleceğin bir
kapısıydı ve ne oldu aydınlanmayın diye
Bu kapı Türk millet inin yüzüne kapandı
Evet ben bir kraliçesi kuramazdım ama ne
yapabilirdim Köy Enstitüsü mantığıyla
çalışan bir kadın Kalkınma Kooperatifi
kurabilirdim Evet çok okudum inceledim
ve
2020'de eylül 2020'de Sınırlı Sorumlu
Ticaret bakanlığına bağlı Fethiye kadın
girişimi üretim işletme ve Kalkınma
kooperatifini kurdum
Ana ne yazık ki pandemi dönemi başladı
Biz bütün hayal ettiklerimizi yapamadık
ama bu dezavantajın süreci biz avantaja
çevirdik Çünkü düşün araştır ve uygula
planla süreciydi bu bizim için rahat
rahat evimizde bunu planladık ve 8 Mart
2021 yerine Bütün kadınlarla birlikte
seksen kadınımızla 40 stand açtık ve
kadınların pandemi döneminde gıda dışı
el emekleriyle ürettikleri her şeyi
satabileceği tezgahlar kurduk ücretsiz
kadınlar haftanın 3 günü o tezgahlara
çıktılar ve hep değişen kadınlar bir
kadına onu zimmet demedik her hafta da
yan yana değişen kadınlar birbirini
tanımayan kadınlar çıktılar ve kendi
ürettikleri pandemi sürecinde sürecinde
kendi ürettikleri el ürünlerinin
satışını yaptılar Böylelikle amaç sadece
para kazanmak değildi onları
sosyalleştirmek birbirleriyle iletişime
sokmaktı ve bunu başarmıştık Evet şimdi
daha sonra Biz neler yaptık
Evet bunu açamıyoruz
şunlardan çalışmıyor arkadaşlar
Evet daha sonrası Biz neler yaptık
coğrafi işaretli ürünlerimiz vardır
kadınlarımızı Bunun üzerinden harekete
geçirebilirdik Evet Kaya halısı
bunlardan birisiydi kayaköy'e gittik
kayaalısı yok Çünkü hiç kimse artık
dokunmuyor tezgahları almışlar yakmışlar
Çünkü satışı olmadığı için biz Evet
Öncelikle eski dokuyanlardan kaya halısı
dokuma tezgahlarını öğrendik bulduk ve
onların aynısını yaptırdık yün ipler
aldık Fethiye Belediyesi ve Ticaret
Odası ile
protokol imzaladık ve Kaya köyde Fethiye
Belediyesi Kaya halısı dokuma atölyesi
açtık ve bunu halk eğitimin ücretsiz
kurslarıyla süsledik ve görünür kıldık
Fethiye Belediyesi olarak da Kaya
halıları sergisi açtık Böylelikle Kaya
halısı görünür oldu ve dokunulan ve
satılan bir ürün haline geldi daha sonra
ikinci ürünümüz dastar
arkadaşlar danslar Fethiye'nin üzümlü ve
İncirköy mahallelerinde kadınların
yıllar öncesinden beri
Maria ile birlikte dokudukları Rum Maria
ile birlikte dokudukları yan yana oturup
dokudukları yüzde yüz pamuk olan bir
dokuma Ama bugüne kadar hep şal
başörtüsü ve ev tekstili olarak
kullanılmış bunu değiştirmeliydik bunu
ekonomiye katmalıydık Evet bunda da
kadınlar artık bunu bırakmıştı Çünkü
metresi 13 liraydı alan yok satan yok
yine burada da karşımıza çıktı Evet buna
üçüncü bir göz lazımdı Biz modacı
değildik Nasıl Bunu daha fazla fiyata
satabilirdik Evet bu çok değerli bir
kumaştı ve değerli ürünlere dönüşmeliydi
Evet bu hem Tarzı unic tarzı ürünlere
çevirmeliydik modacı arayışına döndü
girdik bu sefer Evet modacı isminin
içerisinde modacı taşın dizaynır geçen
herkese ürün gönderdik metrelerce
metrelerce en sonunda İstanbul'dan
İbrahim gökyar ve İspanyol modacı
beyatris'le anlaştık Evet
2021'de başlayan sürecimizi İstanbul
Craft İstanbul defilesi ile ünlü
modacılarla birlikte ilk defilemizi
yaptık Fethiye Belediyesi ve Fethiye
Ticaret Odası ile birlikte Kaya halısı
seydiler kelime ve danslardan yapılan
kıyafetlerimizle burada bir defile
yaptık Daha sonrası Art Ankara'ya
katıldık Fırat Neziroğlu ve Didem Çapa
ile birlikte ünlü Dokumacılar Artık bize
ulaşıyordu biz onlar için çok
koşturmuştuk Demek ki bu işi başarmıştık
Daha sonrası Türkiye dokuma atlasına
girdik Burada da bir defile yaptık o
defilede de o Atlas içerisinde de
Fethiye üzümlü olarak yer aldık Evet
Daha sonrasında Türkiye'nin marka
Kooperatifleri arasına seçildik
Ve bu çok önemli arkadaşlar Birleşmiş
Milletler tarafından o dönemde 960 kadın
Kalkınma Kooperatifi arasında
desteklenmesi gereken ilk 40 kooperatif
arasına seçildik 1750 dolar bize para
verdiler çok azdı ama bizim için çok
önemli değil Çünkü uluslararası çapta
tanınır olmuştu bize bütün kapıları açan
bu projeye kabul görmek oldu Daha
sonrasında geka Güney Ege Kalkınma
Ajansı bize 60 bin liralık
60 bin liralık bir destek verdi ve
stratejik plan ilk 5 yılımızı bizim
planlamışlardı Demek ki bizde Likya
kadınını ışığını görmüşlerdi Evet daha
sonra
fetavm yönetim kurulu fetah Turizm
tanıtım Vakfı birçok kapsamı var orada
yönetim kurulu üyeliğine başlamıştım
yine yönetim kurulu üyesi olan toi Care
genel Türkiye genel müdürü ile birlikte
çalışıyorduk O da
yönetim kurulu üyesiydi ve birlikte lums
oflâ başlattık projesini yaptık Evet
likya'nın ilmekleriydi bu da evet bu
bizim için çok değerliydi arkadaşlar ve
bizi Maddi manevi Çok üst boyuta taşıyan
bir projeydi Yaklaşık 40 bin euro aldık
ondan da ve böylelikle biz ne yaptık
hemen Evet biz bu arada şunu söylemeyi
unuttum biz Kar amacı gütmeyen bir
kooperatifiz evet
terzi yetiştirebilmek için dikiş
atölyesini kurduk dikiş atölyesinin
içerisine nakış atölyemizi de kurduk ve
kadınlarla birlikte bunu kendimiz devam
ettirdik bu bütün defilelerde
kullandığımız ürünlerin satışını
yapmamız gerekirdi ve en iyi alıcının
olduğu yer görecekti Biz bir mağaza daha
açtık Fethiye mağazasının yanında ek
olarak göcek'teki mağazada satışa
çıkardığımız ürünler artık binlerce lira
değerindeydi göcekteki mağazada
kadınlarımız yer aldı gördüler nereye
geldiklerini gördüler ve daha sonra
kedev kadın evin değerlendirme Vakfı bir
kadın ebeveyn değerlendirme vakfına üye
olduk ve bu üyelikte Onlar bizden şunu
istediler yaptığınız her çalışmayı
kataloğa çevirin Evet bir proje daha
yazdık 25 bin liralık bir projeydi bu
onu da kazandık ve katalog çekimi yaptık
yine İstanbul'dan ünlü mankenler geldi
Onlarla birlikte kat sosumuzu hazırladık
ve e kataloğa çevirdik Artık tüm dünya
bizi görebiliyordu Evet biz hep ulusal
ve uluslararası çapta defileler yaptık
İstanbul Ankara bizi tanımaya başladı
İstanbul Ankara gelip üzümlü'den
dokumalar almaya başladı üzümlü kadınlar
bunun neresindeydi bizim yaptıklarımızı
görsünler diye biz üzümlü festivalinde
yeşil üzümlü dastar defilesi yaptık bunu
da kimlerle yaptık kooperatifimizin
kadın ortakları ve Fethiye Belediyesinin
değerli çalışanları kadın çalışanları
ile 19 kişilik bir defile ekibi kurduk
bu defilede hep birlikte bütün
ürünlerimizi sergiledik artı
likya'nın ilmekleri lumsofea bunda da
Fethiye Belediyesi ve kooperatif
ortaklarıyla 9 kişilik bir defile yaptı
Bizim amacımız zaten Kadınlar arası
buluşmayı sağlamaktı bunu başarmıştık
STK ve kurumlarla Kooperatifi
birleştirmiştik
Evet Daha sonrasında Bizim sadece 2-3
mahallemiz yok 41 mahallemiz var 41
mahalleyi de birbirine bağlamak
zorundaydık ve
Esenköy mahallemizde de Kolan kursu
kilim kursu ve Don't destesini harekete
geçirdik orada da çalışmalarımız devam
etmekte Evet bir şey eksik kalmıştı Bu
da gıdaydı Evet bizim Paramız yoktu
gıdaölyemiz yoktu gıdaölyesi olmayınca
da merdiven altı gıda satışına hiç
girmedik yasal değildi ne yapmalıydık
yine proje yazmalıydık Ticaret Bakanlığı
proje yazdık 150.000 Lira hibe aldık
Evet biz para kazanmadığımız için
kendimiz para almadığımız için 100 bin
lira da kooperatifle koyduk ve 250 bin
liraya yasal standartlara uygun bir gıda
atölyesi kurduk gıdaölyesi mevsimsel
gıdalar dışında aşevi olarak da
kullandık şu an Depremzede
vatandaşlarımıza günlük sıcak yemeğin
çıkarıldığı Belediyenin en değerli
halkalarından Biri haline getirdik
ikinci hedefimiz mide markalaşmaya
ulaşmıştık gıdada da Fethiye Likya
markasıyla artık her yerde Fethiye'nin
ürünleri yer almaktaydı Evet gıda
atölyesinde 1 2 aşamayı
gerçekleştirmiştik bizim ürettiğimiz
bütün ürünler için bir domatesle ilgili
bir fabrika kurmamız lazımdı Evet bunun
için altyapısını hazırladık tam proje
aşımı yine proje aşamasına geldik Kınık
organize sanayi bölgesinde yan ilçemizde
kurulmuş olan Bir fabrikanın işletme
teklifi geldi Evet yeniden projeyi
kapattık ve onun kabul ettik Artık
Fethiye olarak Seydikemer olarak da bir
salça kurutulmuş domates toz domates
aklınıza ne geliyorsa sebze meyve
alanında bir fabrikamız olacaktı
üçüncüsü Evet her et hiç kullanıyor
mutfak mirasına girmemiz gerekiyordu
Alanya Belediyesi bunu çok güzel yapmış
niçin bizde olmasındı Biz de yapacağız
ve bunu da da yerimizi alacağız
arkadaşlar bizim
hiçbir şey demeyin o kadar çok şeyimiz
var ki insanlar yaptıkları peynirli pide
ile girmişler Bizimki nelerimiz var
Evet en önemlisi de arkadaşlar gıda
atölyesini kurmamızdaki sebep Kayaköy
dostluk barış ve dünya gastronomi köyüne
çevirmekti Evet birlikte yaşadığımız tüm
renklerin mutfaklarıyla bir araya
gelmekte Evet pieton Pier diyen Bir
liderin çocuklarıydık Biz ne dedi Yurtta
sulh cihanda sulh Biz müzik siyaset din
değil ırk hiçbir şekilde bir araya
gelemedik dünyanın hiçbir ülkesiyle ama
gıda da belki gelebilirdik Çünkü
hepimizin karnı aynı duyuyordu Evet Daha
sonrasında neler yapmalıydık bunların
hepsini ülkemize fethiyemize
kazandırmalıydık Biz ne için bu işleri
yaptık kadınları bu döngünün içerisine
koymalıydık kadınları eğitmeliydik Çünkü
Yarını düşünüyorsak tohum ekiyorduk 10
yıl sonrasını düşünüyorsak ağaç
dikiyorduk 100 Yıl sonrasını
düşünüyorsak da ne yapmalıydık halkı
eğitmeliydik Biz Bunda bu yeşil
hareketlilik döngüsünü yağlamak için
kadınlarla girdik ve kadınların
başlattığı bir düzende çocuklarına
eğittik çocukları eğitilmiş olan bir
ülkenin de yarınları eğitilmiş demektir
Bunu başarabilmek için fethiyemizde
sürdürülebilirliğimizi kooperatifimizin
sürdürülebilirliğini sağlamak için de
Yetişkin ve gençlik kampları kurup bunu
12 aya yayıp Maddi manevi kazanç
sağlayıp hem kadınlarımıza hem
çocuklarımızı bu döngüsel yeşil
hareketliliğin içinde var edebilmek için
çalışmalarımız sonsuz devam etmekte
hızlı bir şekilde ve Fethiye Belediyesi
her alanda Fethiye belediye personeli
her alanda bilmediğimiz her soruyu
sorduğumuz en büyük bizim başucu
kaynağımız her türlü yardımlarından
dolayı teşekkür ediyoruz Biz ilk başta
ne dedik para kazanmak değil sosyal
iletişimdi sosyal Bağlar işbirlikçi
bağlardı bunu kurduğumuza inanıyorum
çünkü defilelerimizi de birlikte
yapıyoruz aşevimizde birlikte yapıyoruz
birlikte oturup kalkıyoruz Çünkü ne için
mutlu yarınlar için bu günü düzgün
yaşarsak eğitimle doldurursak Yarınlarda
çağdaş modern olmamamız için hiçbir
sebep yok arkadaşlar beni dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]